I've read that you actually practice and
dreamed of accepting a Grammy true yes
you know unlike nights I couldn't sleep
as a kid like I would just like close my
eyes and imagine my my acceptance speech
like me up there and you know I would
see Alicia Keys you know in the audience
and she's hosting this year right which
is crazy I won't ask you to tell us what
you said because I think that you're
gonna get a chance to deliver it and her
doesn't only sing she plays the guitar
drums bass and piano
born Gabriella Wilson she was a child
prodigy who had performed on national TV
when she was 10 I was looking at old
videos of you as a little girl and you
were so poised and your voice was so
strong what was that little girl like I
was just having a good time
I just loved music so much I was going
to regular school I would fly to New
York playing Alicia Keys song leave the
next day I'd be on the playground having
a good time you know like a normal kids
when did you realize this thing that you
do that you were really good at it in
terms of your voice I don't know if I
ever realized it I think the people
around me did before I did I just did it
because I loved it you didn't think you
had a good voice I guess I I guess I
kind of had a little bit of a cockiness
about me as a kid like yeah I could do
this you know I mean how did you go from
Gabby to her it wasn't much of a
transformation but more so like a
transition I was always trying to figure
out who I was as an artist I started to
experience what becoming a young woman
was life yours for you they're tougher
those people oh absolutely
that age that's that time period where
your insecurities form you start to
second-guess here everything is you know
the end of the world I just remember
saying I'm never gonna be this girl that
falls for the wrong guy I'm never gonna
do this and do that I'm gonna be smart
about him perfect you know that game
mistakes didn't go very well I actually
experienced those mistakes I experienced
you know my first heartbreak and I've
always kind of internalized
everything but music was my my way of of
expression and I said I'll never be that
girl I became her so her stands for what
having everything revealed and what are
you revealing
everything I think if I can't even see
your face you're not revealing
everything right I guess everything
below the surface because that's who I
am it's not what you see it's all about
my message how are you handling the
thing I've been doing shows I've been
like you know receiving tweets and fan
letters and things like that of people
saying that I've changed their lives of
people saying that I've saved them that
I got them through heartbreak Janet
Jackson told me that I got her through
her pregnancy like like I feel like now
my purpose is so much greater than it
was a few years ago I didn't think
anybody was gonna relate to my stories
so is it kind of a dream come true right
now I'm living my dream like every
single day like I was just talking about
how two years ago I made a vision board
and I put down all these goals a Grammy
nomination was on there but now I have
five and it's like wow the power of a
really senior what your life can be and
making that that vision come to life is
just it's crazy